大家好
今天不是一起活了
今天是一个
一个下雨
你们觉得这个水游戏吗
路过温
其实我哥给我做的
我也是被工作宰了
你只需要三个
就没让AI帮你出出来
一个像这样的路过温
那就工作台的
就是我心动
我比较的学习的生活的
那我现在就让我
介绍一下我的工作台
就很健康的
这是我的工作台
然后左边是一夜的等方了
一上面是学习
生活和家务务
这三个模块
还是让我工作工作
学习
来转去这些经验的
下面
还有我最喜欢的三个模块
就是小麦布
世界和背包模块
那我们一起来看一下
这三个模块是长什么样的吧
首先是这个世界很快
我用AI打造了一个
我的世界的游戏场景
像这些是移动
也可以按WASD
这里就跳
往后走
这些功能兴神的
接下来这里还有一系列
我挖过
并且我背包里面有我的东西
还平下矿
打怪
如果死了
后上没选了
还这里还会有提示
这是我们的小麦布模块
这这里会显示一些
我们可能在平常玩我的世界
是损消用的原料
而这里
就是我们合成之后的
体验稿
师傅
实践
钻实践
这些东西
第三个就是背包
是用我的世界里面
红缓的一些格子里面存放的一些物品
比如说
石稿
乌贵
石套
木箭
还有钻实箭这些
什么
你还把孩子自己玩
工作台
没事
这可是有家人所的屁股
家人所
共同思议
就是你点
然后就可以上锁
这样还就再也动不了里面的东西了
什么
你说你刚才没有在我的工作台里面
看到这个家人所吗
那是因为
这其实是我弟的工作台
那么以上就是我工作台的分享
如果您也感兴趣的话
你的离婚区交出你的工作台吧
那么下期视频再见
我再见